cross-site request forgery CSRF is the
third big web attack I've talked about
cross-site scripting in the past I've
talked about sequel injection this is
number three and it's the lesser-known
one web browsers are fairly trusting
things um I've said this before if you
give them some code to run
they don't cast a value judgment on it
they can't tell if it's malicious they
will just run it now this was this was
kind of okay in the early days of the
web when there wasn't online banking and
things like that you know the worst you
can do is it's put a comment somewhere
um nowadays a bit more complicated the
web runs on data being sent back and
forth and that date can be encoded in a
couple of ways you can have what's
called a get request and that's like if
you if you look up you're using this on
desktop and you look up at the the you
know browser address bar you'll see
youtube.com slash watch to name the page
and then a question mark and then V
equals string of characters that means
that you're going to the watch page and
then the rest of that gets stripped off
and sent to the logic at YouTube which
says I want this video to pull these
details out the database there's another
way of doing that called post which is
the kind of thing where you have a form
with a button at the bottom of it and
when you hit go then all that data gets
bundled up and sent along with the
request but not in the address bar and
traditionally that if you put it in the
address bar it's designed for fetching
data it's called a get so that means
that you can take this YouTube URL and
copy and paste it to somewhere else and
just bundling the data up like when you
click go on a form it's called a post
and that's meant for writing things want
things that happen once so that when you
hit refresh or go back to the same page
it doesn't do the same thing twice so if
you enter a comment um it doesn't put
all your comments details in the URL bar
and you can't copy and paste that to a
friend
and they'll post the same comment and
that's that's reasonably good for the
early days of the web but since then
it's got a bit more complicated let's
say you have a form on your website for
an online bank so let's design a really
bad online bank for
let's have send some money from your
account to this account number and send
this much and then there's a go button
and let's say that as long as you're
logged in you know as long as you've
been through all the authentication
checks and you know use that little chip
and pin device if your password to type
in you've got access to that form you
type in the account number you type in
how much you're transmitting you select
go first of all this won't use a get
request it won't appear up top like
YouTube does it'll button it up as a
post it'll send the request and your
bank will send back that it's done but
the trouble is that form is well almost
public you know how it's designed so
let's imagine you set up a fake web page
somewhere else that has that form on it
and maybe just maybe you hide some of
those details so they're already typed
in so it already has your account number
in it and say a thousand pounds and then
when someone comes along and they want
to put a comment on your website so
let's design a really malicious blog
let's let's call it my awesome blog and
let's write some really inflammatory
content that people will love to comment
on and here is a comment box but off
here of off screen where they can't see
it or even completely invisible is a box
that says account number prefilled with
your account number amount a thousand
pounds I've written 100 100 patents
because apparently my my hand has lower
ambitions than my brain does and when
you click that go but it's not going to
my awesome blog it goes to the really
badly designed online bank which
promptly says oh we've got a request
here double all this blog nonsense is
about but look we've got an account
number we've got some money transfer it
because we've already been authorized
because you logged into your online bank
in that other tab while you were bored
and well great the money has gone and it
gets worse than that because if you've
noticed when you type a comment on
YouTube new clicked post it doesn't
the whole page back like it used to in
the early days of the web now it does it
all in the background silently and just
send a thing back saying yeah that's
fine no worries well that would work
with this too you wouldn't even need to
click the Go button it could just be
that when I load up my site my malicious
awesome blog it just creates that forum
in the background and sends off that
request there's a few things in browsers
designed to stop me doing that but there
are ways around them now that's
obviously quite a big problem online
banks are generally not designed that
way unless they're designed
incompetently
but a lot of web forums a lot of smaller
sites have problems like that if you've
ever designed something where they
delete your account button then
frequently it just goes to something
like slash delete with maybe you know
confirm true on it and you assume that
the only time that forum will be visible
is when the user is logged in and has
clicked no I really want to delete my
account I could copy that delete your
account form and just put it in the
background of my completely irrelevant
web page somewhere else and you wouldn't
even see that it is fired because it's
all happened in the background using
modern web technologies and you wouldn't
notice it would delete your account
quietly in the background because that
form that delete your account form of
that transfer the money form hasn't
checked where the request is coming from
there was something in what's called
HTTP the hypertext Transfer Protocol the
very basics of the web designed to stop
this and it's called the referer header
and it means that when you click a link
or submit a form it includes a things
has referrer
this site so you know if the form
request is coming from the actual online
bank or the actual delete your request
form and not some malicious site
elsewhere trouble is if you start
checking for that a lot of users start
complaining because that refer header
isn't always sent like it should maybe
you've got an advert blocker or maybe
you've got some kind of privacy tool
that's blocking that as well the way to
get around that is a one-time key what
the Americans call the nonce at which
the British definitely do not call the
nonce um the one-time key works by the
form on your website generating a unique
code can be anything just a random
string of characters each time you
create the form and then storing that
character and saying write anything that
comes back anything that I see needs to
have this token with it and this this
code this token you've generated is in
the form as well completely hidden
invisible to the user is something that
says token random string of characters I
think I just wrote a number played a hum
this random string R is meaningless but
what it represents is that this form
that I just made and I just sent out the
user is the one that's coming back so
meanwhile over on on my malicious
awesome blog I don't know what this
token is I can't possibly know what this
token is because it's changes per user
and it changes every time the form is
requested or at least every few minutes
and if you copy that form if you take
that token and try and use it 5 minutes
later or 10 minutes later on a form
that's already been submitted or for a
different person or for any one of these
things now look at that token and I'll
go that's wrong not having that and
suddenly cross-site request forgery
doesn't work anymore and there are still
theoretical attacks and and lucky flukes
that could get past this but in general
that solves it so if you're designing
web forms for anything which which is
permanent anything like deleting an
account posting a comment authorizing
someone or even transferring money if
you're not using this this is a pretty
big security hole and if the site's
you're using aren't using it well you
never know what might happen when you go
to some malicious blog somewhere out
there so that's cross-site request
forgery and it is it's the third attack
and everyone knows about XSS if you're a
web developer cross-site scripting XSS
is the one you know about SQL injection
database attacks are the one you know
about but this this one went under the
radar for a long time and there's still
a lot of developers that don't know
about it so if your design
site or using a site that has anything
kind of permanent to it have a look and
see if a tokens being sent because if it
isn't might be a bit of a security
holder
you start with a script tag and then
everything stops you've got a closing
script tag down here nothing in this
section will actually appear on the
users screen what you now let's say I
type in Tom with a quote mark in it